[Music]
all right welcome back to chappelle's
[ __ ] world my guest today
the man himself
mr lacrosse wisconsin's finest damn
right nick
the vampire werewolf
david
it's so funny i listen i've never seen
someone shout out their city more than
you have i mean it seems to come up a
lot in conversation yeah if i'm not
going to miss an opportunity and also i
i think i do it uh for you as well yeah
that's true you know
like every time anytime anyone talks
about wisconsin in conversation i go
you're been a lacrosse
i have to ask i've never been there but
i i mean
it's not like small town like right
uh it's it's it's
to here it's a small town it's 52 000
people but it has like something this
guy's got all the facts
i couldn't tell you about mesa arizona
how many people are out there it's 50
2008 18.
that checks out is that accurate huh
that check
yeah did you look it up oh i was like
casey found out uh you can if you want
because it's 50 2008 18. uh actually
they might have had us they might have
had a census since uh saw the signs but
how like
what is it
shirt outside are you cold uh i i forgot
i want to wrap my own merch oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah
uh this is all promo promo but yeah it's
kind of it's kind of a a small town feel
a little bit but it's also a big college
town there's three different colleges
yeah um and uh
so it's got like a nightlife a little
bit as we've just yeah yeah yeah the
dark underbelly of wisconsin wisconsin
as we talked about is that what they
call it that's what we called about on
king of the sting when we brought in
that video of the uh oh yeah the bride
getting in the bride getting the fight
yeah
a little bit of racial tension yeah
which is not common in lacrosse
wisconsin i assume
i don't know because you i mean you seem
to be sitting here down here with me
[Laughter]
so i don't i don't imagine there being
racial tension in uh
lacrosse wisconsin uh not really there's
a mixing of communities though there's a
lot of hmong refugees uh really yeah
after the vietnam war minneapolis and
that's like uh what
uh gran torino is about like uh i love i
love that [ __ ] yeah they're among
refugees and they're yeah listen but
there's a lot there's a lot was that
based out of the cross uh no it was in
minneapolis but like just that
i'm only two and a half hours from
minneapolis yeah so or lacrosse's yeah
so that's oh that's the nearest major
major city yep to you yeah so you fly in
minneapolis you have to drive two hours
yep yep or you can you can usually fly
minneapolis to la crosse uh if you want
but i usually just fly to lacrosse yeah
they got an airport minneapolis they got
an airport yeah it's half hour yeah on
some puddle jumper that you don't feel
safe on usually all those ones that like
the
uh no i've never been on a propeller
[Laughter]
[Music]
it we keep it real very g rated clean it
up yeah clearly clean it up nick
these kids i swear these kids from la
crosse wisconsin they're all the same
they're all they're all the same they're
they're you know they got crazy
attitudes they drink
a little bit okay that's all accurate
no but so
dude
you you've intrigued me
you always intrigued me because there's
so much about you i always think about
like anyone behind the scenes
like always like
because yeah you you're kind of like
guiding and you know you're producing
you know just like this guy casey here
but like who has to come on cats after
dark pretty soon oh yeah you do and um
but you you have these intriguing things
and one of the more intriguing things
that caught my attention about you
is more recent
is your fandom for
corey feldman felt damn phil
what is that feldtham that's his fans oh
is that what he calls himself yeah oh he
actually calls his fans like a thing
the cruz the feld fam or or if you like
him you're a fel feldhammer
spelled it which that one really doesn't
that's a pretty poor um
like
filter
yeah felt hammer that's kind of like
yeah it's weak but yeah it doesn't mean
it has no it has nothing i don't know it
just doesn't make any sense yeah yeah
but how
okay how does one
become a fan
of corey feldman because obviously
okay no no no no no let me let me take
that back
movies i get yeah
yeah self-explanatory classics classics
killers
goonies goonies
stand by me standby is probably my
favorite uh teenage mutant ninja ninja
turtles you know he was one of did you
know he was one of the voices yeah yeah
i don't i remember which turtle he was
the voice
uh for
i think donatello
watch me if i if i'm right y'all better
give me a million i think it was
michelangelo
no
oh you got it damn it was i was [ __ ]
right dude yes i wish i wish we had your
little uh we're gonna have to cut that i
i can't have that out in public
if there's one thing you'll learn about
casey you don't edit out anything
it's my one policy
it all stays in and all it all [ __ ]
stays in with casey
but yeah anyways
so yes fan of his movies i get
how did you how does one become a fan of
his music honestly i didn't yeah because
i didn't know he actually did it but
yeah so
it's it's more
i became a fan through this journey but
it was more uh uh
out of a fighting for principle and
fairness um so
a couple weeks ago on my podcast another
podcast show yep uh my co-host pat
uh he recently discovered twitter like
just this year how do you just discover
it he didn't dis discover it but he went
on there and he just i don't listen i
don't have it yeah but i didn't just
discover it yeah yeah like i know it
exists he and he knew it exists too but
i didn't think he really understood how
it could be a little utilitarian and he
he just discovered it and he's like
having some fun with it and it's so
funny he he started it and he like
didn't change his username so he's he's
pat like eight seven six nine nine nine
three four four four but uh
so i don't know what spurred him to go
on there at first but he starts uh
following accounts that interest him and
one of the accounts was corey feldman
who
since he's been a child was like i don't
know he's one of i think michael
jackson's victims essentially and became
obsessed with
that's what he said right yeah and but
he was also obsessed with michael and
like imitated him from a young age and
was always performing oh he still
intimidates him
you want to edit that out
you know the rule
but uh yeah he he still does to this day
on stage and it's actually a pretty
uncanny impression but uh
yeah so pat
starts following him sees that he's
releasing
and this was shocking in itself his love
left
6 cd box set for uh the low low price of
350 the low low price
and so pat starts like trolling him
first he sees this then a couple weeks
later corey then drops the price down to
222 dollars and naturally yeah he
announces that he's gonna have a concert
in hollywood he's dropping the price for
in honor of two two two day because it
was february 22nd tuesday the other day
um and that was a whole thing to corey
because of corey haim they both love the
number two yeah yeah i i can't remember
the exact details but he drops the price
so pat tweets at him he's all pissed off
he's like why am i being punished my
wife bought this for me right away
because i'm the biggest corey feldman
fan then weeks later you dropped the
price and i'm the one that's screwed
even though i'm your biggest supporter
yeah yeah and i immediately just hopped
on because like i said it's a principle
of thing that is pretty [ __ ] and i hop
in i'm like that's
why are you punishing your most loyal
fans we're here to support you
uh and i even sent him and he he replied
he immediately replied he's pretty
active on twitter and he was like uh i'm
pretty sure all companies have sales uh
this is this is a hundred percent normal
like i'm sorry you
i'm sorry whatever and he wrote back
yeah yeah that is [ __ ] amazing it was
and it was one of those things where all
of a sudden there's like replies the
next morning were you were you expecting
replies from corey feldman kind of
because he's so active on twitter okay
there's a lot of replies on there but
it's usually the fans and like retweets
and stuff but he is active on there but
it was a nice surprise the next morning
when he woke up uh and he had replied so
then it was like game on yeah now we
have a back and forth and i was like
well actually corey it's a pretty common
practice called price matching uh and i
sent him a week uh wikipedia article to
like a number of companies that have
implemented price matching through this
very thing you don't want to punish the
people who get there first no no so if
usually when you bring your seat in uh
some place there's like a window and if
they've dropped the price in those four
weeks you can honor it and you'll get a
refund so that's why i told them a bunch
of people jumped on they're like yeah
it's [ __ ] he's just he's having
trouble hawking his his crap to other
people yeah and then uh i think it was
actually those trolls piling on because
i just was trying to have honest
discourse yeah yeah yeah yeah you don't
seem like a man that's trying to troll
uh people a little bit but still not
nice
oh nick's got trolling in him just not
in a mean way it's more of a like left
yeah some people are [ __ ] mean about
it yeah yeah you know if you're just
calling people like uh i would never say
this but people this gets thrown around
online a lot you're like oh you're gay
like there's no like creativity there
what you want to do is like let the
person you're trolling talk like let
them yeah dictate where it goes it's
like it's like uh that's basically like
dealing with a heckler yeah you know a
heckler you're going to let [ __ ]
okay
say something because we're listening
and we're paying attention and that's
how we [ __ ] up hecklers and they are all
of a sudden nervous because they have
eyeballs on them and they're not used to
that so they'll say something exactly
gives you just material
um but yeah so then with those other
trolls piling then he blocked me um what
yeah
he didn't unblock you yet uh he he
didn't unblock me and that was part of
the reason i wanted to go to what is a
kc i was gonna just say like a block is
just as good as a follow
[Laughter]
i do see that online like people has
like a feather in their cap like oh this
person blocked me i don't think it's
it's that cool but it is a sign of just
me
that hurts your heart yeah and you still
support him you you still went to his
[ __ ] concert after the block right
yeah i didn't just go to his concert i i
made custom corey feldman t-shirts uh
did they say cory blocked me
they said official corey feldman
merchandise
oh it does yeah
and actually so like i procrastinated on
this because like i said the concert was
gonna be on february 22nd and uh we had
talked about making t-shirts a lot of
the guy uh my buddy brian who edits my
podcast he lives in wisconsin he loved
this corey feldman thing because he's
heard stories from him for years so he
was the one that really like pushed me
like we should definitely make this
thing he's like i'll fly out we'll film
it um we'll do it right and he was like
yeah we should get t-shirts and i kind
of procrastinated and then i woke up
tuesday or i guess it was monday evening
i was like i was like oh man i wonder if
there's any place you can get uh custom
t-shirts uh same day delivery or like
finished in la and i googled uh i
googled same-day custom t-shirts
we'll take a little break from this
episode with the lovely nick davis and
we'll talk about the kratom that's
killing the game right now and it is
happy hippo
all right i started using kratom uh just
to fire up this brand a little bit just
to get popping before show before a
podcast or before skateboarding whatever
i want to do uh it's one of the dopest
focused products that i think i've been
using uh ever since i started so why
don't you guys visit happyhippos.com
and use promo code thick boy for 20 off
for life use that code as many times as
you want so again visit happyhippos.com
promo code dickboy for 20
off por vida
first of all the level of commitment
but
and you have in-house as a felt hamper
in hollywood
is it felt hammer right yeah i'm i'm
part of the fell fam i felt hammer yeah
on hollywood boulevard there is a place
and the the name of the store is same
day custom t-shirts it was exactly what
i googled it it was it was really nice
the guy was awesome he hooked it up i
had a t-shirt i walked out to uh the
store with t-shirts hour and a half how
many did you have printed uh six because
we had four people going and then there
were two extras we'll probably do some
sort of giveaway with uh so i made the
t-shirts then did you hear that
he said some sort of gif
uh
funniest comment
on this episode okay we'll do that we'll
do that and you have to be following
another podcast show
the podcast so did you get one of these
uh do you have a picture of the shirts
um
we can send one from uh cats after dark
okay
so to get a [ __ ] t-shirt or that
first uh post right there actually on
the screen
what
there's part of the t-shirt
my belly and titties are kind of covered
you get the picture yeah yeah you can
fix it anyway so get one of those
[ __ ] the funniest the funniest
comment uh yeah uh funniest comment
yeah you have to name three of your
favorite corey feldman songs because he
can be following another podcast network
youtube channel he has a lot of [ __ ]
songs that's why i was like how the [ __ ]
and then i
because we talked about it on cats after
dark and then i started taking a deep
dive into his music world he's been
doing this for a minute yeah and and i
had no [ __ ] clue the first album he
has is called former child actor
that's actually pretty good i thought it
was a very creative name i was like well
let me give you a listen and then he
does this performance on a howard stern
show it was like [ __ ]
crazy everybody's like all dressed up he
had his angels
oh no not that one that was
that was watching performance so
yeah i went down a rabbit hole and you
feel like you're in a like a different
universe when you watch his stuff like
that's how [ __ ]
far out there it is the weird thing is
like the music is obviously [ __ ] uh but
his beats are good but
but he he's he's like a natural-born
performer he is he it's very odd
performing but it's like so natural like
it's like oh like i don't feel like he's
like out of his element yeah i think
there's just has to be this thing if
you're like on stage in front of people
where like you just like
kind of lose yourself
and
when you're like delusional you're easy
it's easier for you to do that yeah i
mean he's up there just [ __ ] rocking
it i mean like talk go to youtube we
don't have to play the audio obviously
but go to youtube and type in corey
feldman what's the youth and they're
like there's this dance move he does
that i'm like oh this guy oh what's up
with the youth is what it's called that
top performance right there
that's that's howard stern it's like
some weird party
fast forward a little bit
to where he like starts singing
look at it right there
and he's got a little person right next
to him that's just like
very offbeat and he's black which just
confused me because i'm like oh you're
supposed to know she's got that rhythm
and he's in a hula skirt and he's in a
hula spirit it's like if you look corey
look at him he's
like killing it
you know don't don't mind howard [ __ ]
stern right there but look at him
and then is that little is that meatball
on blackface
i'm not sure what
what uh casey said
uh but i think i might have stole his
joke no no it was a good one
[Laughter]
but look at him
i mean it's a little hectic but i was i
don't know i'm just like oddly
fascinated and i could see
he would probably have a cult following
dude they had him on good morning
america
that's when he had the angels yeah he
was on good morning america and he was
just [ __ ]
going off like type in uh just corey
feldman music i guess or cory filming
gma
it's crazy uh
yes
but even but like he even he'll even try
to look like michael jackson
in a sense
there's his angels there's his angel
he's married to
i believe
the blonde on the keyboard now yeah if
that's
courtney i'm getting more of an edward
scissorhands vibe than a michael jackson
oh this one yeah
look at him
see he can move he can move
candy though
but is
it he'll even try to sing like him
like that that one that one new song
that he [ __ ] dropped
uh
come back
the comeback king oh yeah that is a
little like uh michael jackson yeah yeah
i'm a comeback come back king ooh
that's all i got but
know what i mean yeah
that song was in my head for literally
like four straight dude and i could see
how
cause i like now i'm addicted
i'm not i'm not i'm not a hammerhead yet
but like or whatever the [ __ ] is [ __ ]
you'd be a hammerhead i'm not a
hammerhead but
it like it's weird it's so weird and out
of place but you know what i bet i bet
he would he would [ __ ] if someone
just helped him with promotion
i bet the [ __ ] new generation of kids
would [ __ ] oh he's got
who
who's that rapper is that curtis again
he's always bringing some he's always
bringing out a rapper
is that you hammer
does kind of look like hammer a little
bit but
it says you said if he had someone
helping him with his promotion i mean
someone's putting him on good morning
america
think he's got all the pushy needs
but i could see a younger generation
like [ __ ] with this heavy yeah
because it's so weird it's so out there
and
some of the fans we saw were like i mean
yeah
yeah what was that [ __ ] like
there was this mother-daughter couple
that was really hitting on my friend pat
uh
that they like both were just like they
basically their bond was over corey
feldman it was crazy the stories they
had like remembering seeing them here
and there and like i don't know they've
they were just
they've been they've been fans yeah they
were there before the comeback they were
there before comeback king because that
because he hadn't made an album in a
while yeah i think that was his first
performance since 2017
so i was proud to be in the in the uh in
the building for it so with that being
said this makes me question all your
musical taste
[Laughter]
right am i right am i right i wish i had
a [ __ ] and i now got to think of a
name for myself to call my fans
all 14 of them uh
the shepelzers
i like it not not a bad start not no not
the best start of the showpelzers
the i'm mad that i couldn't think of
something right off the bat i know
usually i was like you guys are like
quick-witted uh
we'll we'll think of something that's
your palsers
but uh my music my music tastes are
eclectic uh i would say what's your
second favorite i know yeah yeah if this
is your top favorite stevie wonder
really yeah yeah no lie for real like
his his greatest hits album is like like
i've listened to that
thousands of times i swear to god i
would have never
yeah okay that's
for those that for those that are
listening to the audio we uh me and nick
were just doing an uh
impression of stevie wonder and that's
what um
if you want to see that we'll just clip
it you know
we'll timestamp that you can put like
those glasses on me but yeah so i i love
kanye west growing up he was like my
favorite high school college and but
then like through his music
discovered like seoul because he's
always sampling [ __ ] yeah and then yeah
discovered something wonderful went off
on stevie are you still kanye west fan
oh yeah i told you i actually haven't
listened to the last two albums because
i don't listen to new music i listen to
podcasts yeah yeah yeah for work like
constantly and [ __ ] um uh i was like you
and i have both joked about this our
musical tastes haven't evolved since
like college because you're just
listening to the same [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah but uh i mean
yeah those first those first five kanye
albums oh yeah i'm a user yeah you know
what i mean i think that's what he calls
his fans right the users dude i even
like the ones that people didn't like
but then
a couple years pass and then people
always go out back to him like like
jesus jesus yes people didn't like that
at first would you but you know what it
like the thing about kanye is what makes
him so smart and so great at what he
does
he makes timeless [ __ ] oh yeah so it's
like it's like oh you won't you probably
won't [ __ ] with jesus right now but
moving forward you will pink ass polo
with the [ __ ] backpack but everybody
know you brought real rap back nobody
had swag man we the rat pack virgil
pyrax darcy snapback ivan diamonds
change the climate
it was just like iggy there's one thing
you don't know about nick davis is
in the back of his pocket he has
some wraps
memorized that just catch you off guard
ninety percent of the rap memorized
every bite
when he did when he did iggy
he did an iggy azalea is it iggy azalea
yeah
right yeah
yeah i was like what is her [ __ ] name
he did an iggy azalea song on king of
the sting i saw it oh you saw it
legendary legendary that was like one of
the first episodes i think i was on oh
really one of the first few like when i
first started he and i was like damn
who's this guy there's a
i edited that clip which is always weird
when i pick a clip that's like kind of
me heavy but i mean that one it was
undeniable though it was undeniable yeah
i mean that was that episode but like i
left it like i [ __ ] up the first time
but then when i started going i left it
on just your face for a while and you're
right
like you're just like you're like oh
damn because you're like
iggy iggy [ __ ] [ __ ]
something like that i don't remember the
lyrics but then have you seen that video
of her uh freestyling
uh
that we can pull up i think that won't
get flagged it won't i don't think so
because oh no yeah because it's like an
iphone [ __ ] yeah yeah it's like iggy's
free yeah freestyle
the subtitles are incredible on this
it's a short clue
[Music]
does the screen record go on the
episodes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
dude almost positive she said the animal
yeah almost positive yeah
yeah i guarantee you
what did you say
oh she did
why you get hyped for that point yeah
yeah sit down yeah yeah yeah yeah
christie
don't talk off mike
matter of fact leave
he's straight up
[ __ ] meatball
anyways you know t.i discovered her
he did and now i think they're like
beefing because she got like two kind of
i don't know
i don't know he was on breakfast club
one time [ __ ] talking [ __ ] about her
really i don't know the exact beef but
they don't like each other anymore it's
weird cuz like
i'm not gonna lie i mean like i
i appreciate a lot of music
you know i really do i i genuinely but
not that yes it's hard it was hard it's
hard for me to catch on board with that
which is fair i'm not dissing iggy
azalea you know she she has an audience
like me saying i don't like her doesn't
[ __ ] take away from her career you
know what i mean
but
when i think about it i'm like
that might be the first thing on this
show that you've been like nah yeah
right yeah i mean you vibe with
everything i vibe with literally [ __ ]
everything but that's that's that's a
big gnaw
[Laughter]
it's tough because like
and every one of my friends was like yo
you got to check out this new icky
that's all i go eat a dick
like what like uh like i i get it i got
it like and unless like you know
iggy respect you i think you're gorgeous
you know what i mean you know not that
she gives a zero [ __ ] about me you know
you know i mean you know shout out to
shout out to her and her
she got a baby and [ __ ] what was the
first album you ever bought
first album i ever bought was uh
dirty rotten imbeciles uh greatest hits
that was uh when i was like
13 or 14. and how it was three albums
together it was or like four was like uh
no three it was uh it's like the almost
the love left out 2.1 boxset
keep [ __ ] up the name
he's going to keep it beltham is going
to
be off dude the phil family is going to
annihilate you on this [ __ ] episode i
was going to say corey's going to block
you but he already ah
no yeah uh it was all punk rock albums
so dirty rotten imbeciles greatest hits
black flag
first four years and then uh gbh
city babies uh revenge 101 ways to kill
a rat
it sounds like the the charlie day
biography
wait what was yours uh nelly country
grammar
[ __ ] yeah
uh
hey nelly you gotta give it up for
[ __ ] nelly he's he's had a hell of a
career that has a hell of a career oh
he's the man i mean his music like
he like just went all like poppy and
[ __ ] and just like got the bags but man
that first album was like that first
album was [ __ ] insane it was like a
new sound and it was like super hardcore
and people didn't even know like yeah
the lyrics of uh um
the first hit uh street sweeper baby
cockroach i mean that's just about going
down the street and doing drive-bys and
[ __ ] yeah exactly meanwhile everyone's
like he's [ __ ] great
i love songs like that where he like
kind of catches you off guard where it's
so poppy and you think it's like an
uplifting song and meanwhile it's
talking about some other [ __ ] i mean i
wouldn't say it was like necessarily uh
uplifting but one song that i never knew
what it was about and then when you
listen to it you're like oh but uh it
was like um
uh it's on the same album no no no no
this is like completely different but
it's a song that uh made me think of
that it was like um
[ __ ] i can't remember i can only read my
name like a billionaire i know i could
only remember the line i'm thinking but
like
in one of the verses he he's like she's
dating the n-word from the street it's
like an old lady oh oh um that's blessed
yeah yes yes yes um
[ __ ]
gosh what is that song bless the union
souls are the guys that sing she likes
me for me
oh really not because
or that guy who played in fargo i think
his name
yeah
but yeah he has a song gosh what is that
song and it's not it's such a soft yeah
yeah i didn't know for like 15 years
what it was about yeah he was dating a
white girl and meanwhile he's he's a
black guy yeah all right so the inward
part that comes in
that that is a black man saying that
gosh if you do blessed you you told
edward from the street
i don't want that on my history yeah
yeah
you can type it it's very liberating
yeah
this is something
oh it's
called i believe it's called i believe
i yeah i believe i believe that love
i think they're from kentucky
where does it say blessed union souls
are from
or maybe they did a show in kentucky and
i saw them one of the two buying that uh
nelly album though really was like a
fork in the road and now today oh pretty
much
dude well i mean it's cincinnati sorry
but you know um you know another song
like that is a [ __ ] uh
obviously we know jumper from third eye
blind is uh oh yeah about abortion no no
no that's good all slides oh okay that
one's about abortion okay gotcha you
know the song black balloons by them
also about abortion now
what about it well that's about heroin
oh we're black balloons yeah um i mean
everybody knows this i mean this it's
like abortion abortion songs
uh jake j cole's j cole's got an
abortion song
smorsha yeah
uh um
but anyways another third eye blind song
never let you go that one's about meth
that they did math you know that's
something they they do did they do i
never let you go
gosh
yes
is this what we do here
oh yeah
[Music]
that song that's not that's that's
impressive
[Laughter]
cause i was like if i because whenever i
try to explain like a song and i try to
do the beat of it it just sounds really
bad yeah so i'm like i'm not gonna
[ __ ] do it
but i have my handy handy dandy uh
fender tim armstrong acoustic hellcat um
shout out to my boy toby morris for
giving that to me shout out to fender
guitars uh but yeah uh
what's that talking about though but
yeah i like i love
i always think they're like a band is
clever when they're able to do that like
let's make this song about meth but
that's make it [ __ ] uplifting like
that killer song
that's about that's a sad song
what's it what what you know song
gosh now i gotta sing it
i don't know i actually don't know how
to play that one i just can't look it's
killing me oh yeah yeah
see i got that one yeah that one's a
that one's a sad song uh
but but you know that's one thing he has
cancer or something
i think it's just [ __ ] uh about a
breakup or something or someone cheating
or something like that but what's funny
about that song it's voted one of the
top in the top um
songs for white people to get down to oh
word
i don't know if they labeled it the way
i said it
you know what i believe you know what i
mean
you know what i believe no pun
intended is uh
the number one song for white people get
down to oh i know what you're going to
say well
you're going to say two three return to
the map
[Laughter]
don't stop believing
that that's good you know you know i
[ __ ] hate that song
yeah i mean it's it's overplayed and
yeah i don't know we're exposing a lot
of stuff that you don't like i know yeah
i never mention anything that i don't
like that's that [ __ ] i don't like
but yeah i don't like hey i can't stand
that [ __ ] song
i just go why why why that of all songs
where do you see
but i like journey i like wheeling the
sky key zones
you want to know why
it's because i worked at a hotel and
they would literally play it i go we
don't have to do that to ourselves why
are we doing that why why would we do
that to ourselves you want this on the
[ __ ] house music during the like
tourists love that [ __ ]
they love it stupidly you know what's so
funny so
it's not funny but interesting i think
about working at a hotel
uh
i worked at a hotel and there was this
event that would come through every year
to arizona and i think it was a bunch of
uh people from china so chinese people
that were coming through and whenever
they would come to
arizona they would dress
in like
western gear
like old western
oh
because they thought that's how
yeah we dressed
yeah and they would come through every
year that and i remember i was because
it was happening when i was when i first
started working at the hotel and i asked
one of the guys to go why are they
dressed like that and they go they they
think that's how we dress out here
because they're like oh arizona and then
they come in the [ __ ] they've seen a
[ __ ] tombstone um
what's it called hell or high water no
oh funny one lawless uh owen wilson
jackie chan oh uh oh what is it shanghai
nights shanghai shanghai new and
shanghai nights yeah is it well uh
i think shanghai nights is a sequel
really
they made a sequel yeah
yep
oh
you got me there but yeah so they
probably all saw that right you know
what i watched the other day this i mean
i know this is a little off music or
whatever but we can talk about whatever
you know i watched the other day that
[ __ ] still cracks me the [ __ ] up
what's that beer fest
classic have you ever seen that oh yeah
dude i [ __ ] love that movie that [ __ ]
i'm like
yeah i'm 35 and that [ __ ] came out like
2006
but that [ __ ] is still [ __ ] funny oh
yeah they don't make comedies like that
no more where it's like i don't know
what you call that like
it's not slapstick
what is it like um
is this is that slapstick that's not
really slapstick what's slapstick
slapstick's like um rob like leslie
nielsen like um that's slapstick yeah
yeah like like gags and yeah stuff which
i i like like
naked gun is slapstick yeah where it's
like
we're like okay you know what you know
what's so dope when i think about it
because liam nee because in those type
of movies you got to have one straight
man
not not saying you can't have a gay man
but i'm talking about straight yeah in
the sense of like the character and liam
neeson is the straight man the whole
time yeah and there's yeah there's just
like crazy [ __ ] going on there's this
crazy [ __ ] going around but he doesn't
make his obliviousness he's a is that
what is that what i'm looking for
i think he's
more now
deadpan like he's still he's goofing
he's doing goof
straight man is the guy who's like you
can't be doing that like oh yeah the
straight man is always like what are you
yeah what are you doing like what that
no this yeah so straight man it's like
logic
yeah logical yeah got it yeah
uh
is the word gag in the definition of
slapstick
let's look it up
they need to take gag out of it give it
a goog
give it a gig
comedy based on deliberately clumsy
actions and humorously embarrassing
events a gag is a clumsy action
you know what i hate about gag is that
it's two definitions
and i'd rather just keep it in the
comedy definition
you know what i mean but like gag
they're like oh you're gagging
i think that's
you know what i mean
i don't know what you mean exactly but
i'm [ __ ] they say that i'm trying to
help me out no you're going to edit this
out
uh i like oh they're gagging
you know what i mean yeah i like
homonyms because that's how you get puns
yeah what is that what's hominem
gosh you graduated i did it uh i didn't
from college from college i didn't oh uh
but um homonym is a word that you know
it yeah i graduated from college yeah
is a word that sounds and is spelt the
same homophone is a word that sounds the
same but it's spelt different
and homonyms they have different
meanings so same word different meanings
yeah so what's up with sending them an
acronym
those are like
oh no no acronyms like you're like
those are two different words you're
looking for
antonym
you know what [ __ ] you guys
i [ __ ] love words i know what i know
hey i know what i know cause i know it
yeah and it's what i know and what i
know is fair
just because i haven't learned it or
seen it doesn't mean i lack intelligence
cheers you know what i'm saying you know
i was gonna say about the first album
thing earlier yeah that was a fork in
the road uh yeah because of
i was like down to a list of buying uh
that
creed creed that's one the like the one
that had with arms right open the the
big the big one yeah yeah uh creed
uh dmx
um
so that probably would have been his
first or second album that was the one
that had um
no stop
it was after that i think it had one
more road to cross and party up and uh
on it okay lose my mind up in here that
yeah that was around the nelly time yeah
and uh and uh
hit one more row to cross yeah morris
today
gotta live my life just one more move to
make that's like kermit the frogs
[Laughter]
uh or red hot chili peppers
californication
that album but it like changes i'm not
i'm not like a massive chili peppers uh
fan i do like i do i like a lot of their
songs and only reason why i say i'm not
like a massive fan because i
i like to respect people that are
massive fans yeah yeah and you know i
don't i'd rather do them justice and be
like yo i'm i'm i like a lot of their
songs but that album specifically i
think is a very phenomenal
album oh yeah dude there's start to
finish that it's dude it's got like so
many [ __ ] sing the ones that were
singles but yeah but then their singles
don't become like songs that you like
hate as much like yeah they're still
they they hold up um yeah that was that
cd was amazing and that video i that was
like middle school california video yeah
yeah yeah it's like a video game
yeah oh man it was so dope uh
i was watching a lot of music videos in
middle school at that time
it was dope
and then like and then like i
so that was like when i first listened
to red hat shooting that was like 99
yeah right around there
oh yeah this [ __ ] is so dope i i have to
watch this when i go home um but then i
listen to their older [ __ ] after this
and like they're so funky back in the
day yeah yeah they're real funky they
kind of found like a happy medium
with it because it was like pretty solid
like
funk which i which i have also just
discovered that i love now you like a
lot of fun yeah i don't like
i couldn't name i like funk songs
usually yeah there's not a lot of fun
like artists and [ __ ] but like like uh
george clinton and [ __ ] yeah yeah good
um
yeah no that's all good that's all great
stuff you know you know what christ we
have about you
whenever you do other people's podcasts
you're like i'm i'm i'm holding the
throne i'm taking
you're taking everybody out as far as
views goes oh yeah
hopefully it's it's it's nick's goal
what the [ __ ] would mark harley get on
this thing
i think my biggest is probably cat okay
well you can't be cat no no no no
or
i know it's ever griffin
yeah so that's your competition yeah i
don't think i can beat that
i think i think that's your competition
um so now i do this part in the episode
where i do rapid fire questions nice
okay
so besides
besides the corey feldman
concert
what was your favorite concert you've
been to
uh
it was uh
have you heard of rhyme stairs
they're uh like atmosphere
i've heard of atmosphere uh yeah so
rhyme sayers is atmosphere's label it's
in minneapolis okay and they uh they
started to put on a a rap festival in
minneapolis that just like continued to
grow and grow and grow and grow yeah and
i went one year
and uh the year i went the headliners
were mac miller
and big boy
calm down meatball calm down he said mac
miller i know mac miller was the like
the best live performer i'd ever seen
like i was always really skeptical about
uh watching or seeing rap live yeah you
know cause like sometimes they get out
of breath dude i always always think
about like
would rappers live a lot of them can't
pull it off like you have to like
and a lot of them are just like boring
and they'll just wrap their songs and
things like oh this is a hit song of
mine i'll just [ __ ] wrap it normally
and it's like no you gotta like do
something yeah mac miller came in he's
jumping just all over the stage singing
every word you hear he's out of breath
but he's actually like rapping yeah and
it was it was amazing and then big boy
saying and like
that year i'd like become obsessed with
his album
that [ __ ] was awesome so you it's it's
funny you say this because you're the
you're the first person first guest i've
had that actually mentioned a festival
yeah uh and i can see it like those
aren't
usually as like the most intimate like
concert like experiences or whatever but
these were dope super close everybody
was so amped when they came on stage
like those are awesome okay i'm trying
to think of other ones that other
non-festival ones that
really stuck out to me
um
one time i had tickets to the course
i mean that was incredible that was
transcendent but uh one time i went to i
went to uh or we had tickets to
the yeezus tour in minneapolis but he he
oh is that when he like canceled yeah he
was cancelling shows all the time this
was because like his
show before that was in canada or
something in some stage
decoration broke or something like i'm
not putting the show on like unless they
can put it on like perfectly but then
the next week dave chappelle not
announced show so we got refunds and
then just bought dave chappelle tickets
oh easy does it yeah it was cool all
right favorite okay uh for you i'll do a
couple favorite band uh
favorite band
i'm trying to
like
so john mayer doesn't have a band he's
just uh he's just no you can say that
like i i mean i love john mayer i i geek
out over john mayer
hey john may stop playing come on this
podcast
john mayer come on the podcast sorry
that was aggressive
you know do we know anyone that knows
him uh
he follows he follows theo he does
theo
uh
i really like eric church who has a band
so this is like all no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no this is all
fair yeah yeah that's all fair uh i love
eric church stevie wonder kanye j cole
there's like kind of those are like
that's just like common i love i love
dude
my favorite one of my top favorite
albums is that b album oh yeah
yeah yeah
i'm gonna be free is experience with
those left i'm talking about culture my
man
looks the [ __ ] man okay favorite
album um
well for you we'll because you like so
much we'll go favorite hip-hop album
maybe favorite rock album rock album um
i haven't listened i rock is like kind
of my blind spot a blind
uh
chris stapleton uh uh yeah yeah his his
first one it wasn't called tennessee
whiskey but that's his big hit yeah it
was the one with tennessee i don't
remember yeah i'm a traveler traveler i
think it was that was okay the first
song is definitely called traveler love
that album
um
hip hop album i mean i [ __ ] love that
that country grammar even though it's
the first up of my body still holds up
uh
those first three kanye cds were all
amazing yeah they're hard to just like
pick
that's like just listing your favorite
i know
um
those three are insane the first i mean
all of his albums are like insane but
like to start off like
you know because some people it takes a
little bit some people have like they'll
have a good first album then it's
usually like their sophomore albums kind
of little a little tricky to follow with
yeah and then the third album they have
like this kind of like junior jump yeah
junior
i'm literally gonna look at my spotify
right now because i'm like drawing a
blank on what like what i've
listened to a lot of oh no that's
perfect because that's a perfect
transition into our
chappelle's playlist
so we do so i do uh so basically i do a
soundtrack for people for each episode
which basically is a soundtrack that is
the vibe of the episode oh
of our artists that we've like talked
about or artists you want to throw in
there we do like 10 to 12 songs uh i'll
go first and i'll do
blessed union souls i i believe
and and then are you guys actually
making these on um yeah so what i do is
like i'll make it yeah i'll make it on
spotify and then i'll put the link in
the description i love that yeah i love
that so and and actually what's cool
about this i want to say this uh since
i've been going on the road and stuff
people actually
do appreciate these playlists so thank
you for actually like taking the time to
like listen to them and enjoy them and i
have gotten messages from people like oh
i never heard of this until you put this
on the
playlist and i've been listening to this
artist so so thank you guys for
you know listening overwhelming with
lots of love
um i think i've uh covered that i like
kanye but i'm just gonna get it out of
the way
my first pick uh kanye family business
wow
i woke up that's a good one i woke up
early this morning with a new state of
ride creative way to rhyme without using
knives and guns keep your nose at the
sky keep your heart to god keep your
face to the rising sun all my edwards
[Laughter]
you know you know what somebody whatever
whenever like for white people whenever
like the song like this if they're
listening to a hip-hop song and then
where it comes up every everyone has a
different way of doing it some will just
say say in word
like in like that word like in word
you know what i'm [ __ ] trying to say
and then some will just be like and then
yeah
[Laughter]
or someone will do the tick-tock thing
goes or whatever
and then some will just say it anyways
[Laughter]
are you watching the kanye dock on
netflix i've seen the first uh episode
and it was amazing i mean it's like
everything he's ever rapped about you're
seeing like literally like the
interactions he's talking about like
yeah right there um so we did that i'll
do you did kanye family business
um
i'll do kanye west never let you down
so
so we'll do two kanye
i will do
um
stevie wonder for once in my life oh
okay
[Music]
i'll do
you brought up george clinton
uh i'll do atomic dog
september
um earth wind and fire
that's that's i'll do
i'll do vultures by john mayer
i'm loving our playlist already i know
this is actually a popping playlist
gone till november uh why clef john
you like that [ __ ] the carnival the
carnival's an album now that's a great
album
damn that just hit me yeah
[ __ ] that's a good one
that's one of those songs like the first
like yeah
[Music]
i'll do i'll do uh
common and i'll do we'll do the song b i
love that
you like took it's like i got an extra
pick because you put a song that i would
pick on there oh yeah
how many were yet
you spelled all these right
it just jinxed me
the aforementioned return of the mac by
mark morrison yeah
wait what was it that we were at i
didn't hear what you said
we got time you got 10. all right we'll
do two more all right so i'll do
damn you did return to the mac
look how [ __ ] not racist i am
every song
hey if they ever try to come after you
nick i'll just show this playlist you
our entire playlist that's that's uh
where's my phone i gotta
figure out
because i'm gonna i'll do something off
nelly
the [ __ ]
i don't know let me type in country
grammar
ride with me yeah i'll do that one
and then my final pick this is like me
getting kind of hipster something like
deep cut because i feel like everything
i've said is very like
which i know this about myself yeah it's
all very mainstream [ __ ] but uh it's
called till i met thee by cody chestnut
this is very like is this folky uh no
it's like he's like he's it's like seoul
um oh god uh he's he's this guy he was
like a
really good singer in like alabama or
georgia or something but he got a
country uh no it's so like oh
he got like addicted to crack
for a while yeah and then
he came back and he got sober and he did
a song with the roots it's called the c
2.0
yeah
i
don't for much these days
and i don't need show me this guys show
me cody
chestnut
i seen this guy if you heard the song
the c 2.0 you've definitely heard this
song with the roots it was very big for
a summer but he's got a whole album um
until i met the is he used to be on
crack
yeah he looks like a very soulful man
he's got a song that get go i used to
smoke crack back in the day
yeah i used to gamble rent money and
lose hey be honest about it i love it
yeah uh he's he's the [ __ ] listen to
some cody chestnut all right i'll check
that out he looks like uh
donald glover there yeah he kind of does
the last picture you were at and i don't
think that's a racial thing i don't
think it's like no no he looks like an
old-ass glover i think other black
people would say that too uh
anything you want to plug nick uh yeah
so uh that another podcast network
youtube channel that's where that corey
feldman video is going to be dropping oh
yeah he's got a chord filming video yeah
vlog the whole night even when i met
corey
uh
i was out on the dance floor by myself
shutting it down when does this come out
thursday thursday
i'd love to have it out hopefully it'll
be there like right after this finishes
so go check but no guarantees um and
that's on the another podcast network
youtube channel and that's like where my
other podcast called another podcast
show is where like that's probably the
thing i put out that i'm like the most
proud of like me and my two buddies we
just have a silly podcast and we do
silly things like uh troll corey feldman
and then i'll be uh
march 10th through the 12th i'll be in
springfield missouri which i heard is
like one of the most popping areas in in
missouri uh and you know not too far
well that's actually quite quite far
from st louis so i wish i could go hang
out with nelly but march 2 12 10 through
the 12th i'll be at springfield missouri
blue room comedy club april 8th and
april 9th wise guys comedy club in salt
lake city and then may 6 just announced
a new club in san diego called mic drop
comedy club shout out to my homies that
are running at casey courier and uh
hillary hudson uh
are you know running that spot so
that'll be may 6th and may 7th and then
a one-nighter in the hometown phoenix uh
stand up live may 12th
boom go see it yeah please do you know
yeah grab your western clothes and come
out yeah yeah when you when you're in
phoenix grab your western gear
you know low ties yeah i'll have two
doors
the saloon yeah we'll have a good time
uh thank you for coming nick thanks for
having me